hello everyone welcome to today's live
broadcast tough target simple with
genotyping using HRM as a direct
approach in research applications I am
Christina mahalik of lab roots and I'll
be your moderator for today's event
today's educational web seminar is
presented by Lavery's the leading
scientific social networking website and
provider of virtual events and webinars
advancing scientific collaboration and
learning this webinar is sponsored by
Canon biomedical canon biomedical a
wholly owned subsidiary of Canon USA
incorporated is focused on empowering
the biomedical research and health care
communities by developing manufacturing
and marketing innovative technologies
and solutions before we begin there are
a few instructions we will be here for
you during this interactive broadcast so
please ask questions or leave us a
comment answers are welcome to you can
do this by hitting the green Q&A button
at the lower left of the presentation
window and typing in your comments and
questions we'll try to get to as many as
we can and we will follow up if we don't
have time to answer all if you want a
better look you can launch the slide
window by clicking on the screen icon in
the lower right hand corner of the slide
window if you can't hear or see the
presentation properly let us know by
clicking on the support button on the
top light or use the Q&A button we'll
make sure we try to resolve any issues
this is also an educational webinar and
thus offers free continuing education
credits after the webinar is over please
click on this de buttons located in the
bottom left hand corner of your web page
and follow the process of painting your
credit now let's get right to today's
presenter we are proud to welcome dr.
Brian McKnight
writing has 15 years of practical
experience Apple laboratory bench and
his work has been published in
peer-reviewed journals and presented at
international conferences in 2008 he
transitioned to industry to
commercialize new biomedical products
including assays reagents and software
brian has been with Canon biomedical
since his reception last year he is
passionate about partnering with life
scientists to develop the next wave a
biomedical solution dr. McNally the
presentation is all yours thanks very
much certainly appreciate the kind
introduction so we're going to go ahead
and get started today on topic tough
targets and simple genotyping and as the
sort of obligatory slide that I have to
put forward to make my colleagues in the
legal department happy all of the can
biomedical products that will show you
in the presentation today are intended
for research use only they are not for
using diagnostic procedures those of you
that relish looking at licensing
information and product specific
disclaimers I encourage you to download
our user guides at Cana biomedical com
or certainly put a request in the Q&A
section we'll go ahead and send that to
you right away the canon biomedical
products that are that are going to be
shown today are going to be available to
you today directly from canon biomedical
in the united states for those of you
that are in the united kingdom and
ireland they are available through a
distributor lab tech which would offer
those products those of you that are in
other countries we're working very hard
on getting our products become available
and those so if you are coming from
another country and you have interest in
these products please just indicate that
in the Q&A box and we'll be happy to
work with getting them available to you
as quickly as possible and finally the
Nova wheel is a trademark of kanna
biomedical incorporated so with that out
of the way the lawyers are all happy a
lot of you might still be scratching
your head cannon at clinical diagnostics
and research and so we get a lot of
different questions about this are you
part of the camera
opening are you part of the printer
company and the answer is yes there are
parent organization and then in this
particular case we're a new wholly owned
subsidiary of that and so the next
thought that didn't often gets asked vs
well you must have something to do with
microscopes or imaging and I think I'm
going to surprise you in the upcoming
slides but with that mine I'd like to
ask all of you how many of you have
heard of can the biomedical before so
we're going to launch a poll right now
and is it in during that polling and you
would go ahead and please just you know
let us know have you heard of can
biomedical before yes or no just gives
me a good sense of the familiarity of
the audience has with us as an
organization so i'll give you a few
seconds to go ahead and click on those
responses
certainly really appreciate you using
the poles are in the course of the
presentation today it's extremely
helpful
alright well thanks again so I'd like to
tell you a little bit about the history
of cannon and we're kinda biomedicals
coming from and I'm going to begin this
with a question that's sort of opened
you know everyone's guessing has anybody
you know does anybody recognize what
this x-ray is and I've got some very
clever answers from giving this
presentation before I had a respondent
answer me that yes this is an x-ray when
I told the next audience that I
previously been told that this is an
x-ray the next audience responded this
is a chest x-ray so both those
statements are true but to help
everybody else this is actually a x-ray
showing a patient with virtual OSIS and
in 1930s this was considered Japan's
national disease rampant disease across
the country affected well over a million
individuals making them very very sick
and so in the late eighteen hundreds
there were direct extra cameras and you
can see an image that was taken from on
a popular electricity magazine you can
see there man holding what would be
considered with direct x-ray in front of
this woman looking for I would spur
closest or some other growth or
something like this well these large
format x-rays were at the time in the
30s very very expensive and it really
needed to sort of a collaborative
approach to then solve this medical
needs that we could had transfer from
x-rays really being only used as a
diagnostic tool to more of a screening
tool and so that's what happened in the
late 30s a medical doctor approached
another medical doctor named Takeshi
knitter I or dr. Miller I and dr. Miller
I was one of the founders of cannon and
it was the first can president served
until nineteen seventy-four this other
doctor brought together an idea that
allow for an indirect x-ray imaging
which would essentially take that chest
x-ray and then expose that on to 35
millimeter film and so cannon saw this
is really a way to contribute to society
and positively in
the individuals within the country that
were suffering from this debilitating
disease and so this collaborative
approach and working with the medical
community to take in advancement
innovate on it and then deploy it
broadly really was one of our first
steps as a company into the world of
diagnostics and so screening in 1939
with the release of the CX 35 this
indirect x-ray camera really helped turn
the tide in stem and epidemic in Japan
of tuberculosis and stepping through
time cannon is constantly interacting
with the medical community to positively
impact our health care and so I would
argue that in the 60s there was the
deployment of these indirect x-ray
cameras out into the field on these
buses so you can see in the image in the
right hand side there's a little bus
that bus is carrying the upgraded
version of these x-ray cameras and this
bus is located in this picture in Nepal
which was also fighting at that time
tuberculosis and I would argue that this
was Cana biomedical or cannons rather
first steps into the idea of point of me
testing is to put in a diagnostic device
on wheels and deploying it to remote
locations around the world those
advancements continued in 1967 can join
forces with the National Cancer Center
in Tokyo now not to focus on infectious
disease but rather to focus now on
cancer in this particular case worked on
developing special imaging technology
that was then used to screen for stomach
cancer and then moving now into current
day in 1997 canon invented the first
digital radiography solution and I've
shown here in a picture on the right
hand side the red proly which is now a
current model that's used around the
world for digital radiography solutions
so we've taken into the film based
approach a collaboration used it
originally to screen for tuberculosis
then went on to point of me testing with
putting that technology onto a bus
broaden the types of diagnosis we could
use through imaging with cancer
detection and then of course now it's
with the step in
to the digital world with a digital
radiography solution and so if the heart
of all of this is really sort of an
imaging a macro sort of based diagnosis
of medical conditions but what we can
see in the biomedical research
communities that we're moving beyond
whole body imaging type solutions it's a
much more cellular and molecular type
solutions and so that's where the field
is going and so can Anakin wants to
continue in that tradition of
collaboration with seeing how that we
can help with the world of solar and
molecular we began that with kenna
biomedical supporting to partnerships
the first one shown here on the left
with t2 Biosystems t2 Biosystems has an
innovative solution coming out of
massachusetts a fully automated sample
to answer molecular diagnostics platform
but first focused it with an FDA
clearance in 2014 on the cam being a
fungal panel and canna biomedical is
working together now with t2 Biosystems
to collaborate on a Lyme disease test
using their pipeline and then another
collaboration that we've begun is with a
Canadian company Spartan Biosciences
they have a point of need device it's a
fully automated sample to answer
solution join a particular gene typing
test that impacts the use of plavix and
this has been cleared for a
point-of-care designation by Health
Canada and so in each of these cases
cannon is bringing it to expertise in
things like IP strategy and core
technologies manufacturing technical
support to these organizations to help
promote their solution and that really
represented our first step in in the
field of molecular testing so what we
want to now begin talk about is really
what kanan's products Cana biomedicals
products are in solutions that are
specifically geared towards you and
we're going to begin with a discussion
of genotyping and then I'm going to talk
about tough targets and genotyping and
how to make that process simple with a
different assay design approach and then
I'll summarize and
questions at the end so before I get too
far along I would like to talk about
sort of tough targets and simple
genotype and I'd like to launch another
poll question which is how many of you
are currently genotyping samples today
so I'm going to launch that poll now and
again the question is do you or anyone
in your laboratory currently genotype
human samples so I'm going to leave this
pull up for a little while and then I'm
going to have a follow-on poll that's
going to address the results of this one
so i'll give you all a few minutes here
or a few seconds here go ahead click yes
or no against you or your laboratory
currently genotype human samples and now
with the results of those for those of
you that answered yes that you're doing
that or your laboratories doing which of
the technology is listed here are you
currently using to do that are you using
next-generation sequencing Sanger
sequencing mass spectrometry pcr-based
methodology or something that's not
listed above
okay this is great i really appreciate
everybody taking the time to answer the
questions with regards to your
genotyping in the current methods that
you use for genotyping and i wanted to
talk about these in the upcoming slides
a little bit more so that everybody
could understand sort of our approach to
genotyping so thing we're going to go
ahead and close those polls
alright so in in slide 16 we're going to
go ahead and start talking about the
different technologies that are used for
genotyping I've listed essentially the
same ones that were in the poll
next-generation sequencing there on the
left hand side very sort of unbiased
approach looking at whole exome whole
genome data in there of course there's
Sanger sequencing a very classic
approach for looking at more targeted
regions of the genome mass spectrometry
is being used of course to identify
variants and then there's a couple of
different methodologies that can be used
with pcr one would be hydrolysis probe
based pcr as commonly known as pac-man
based pc are there are other fluorescent
probe labeled or 4s labeled probe based
pcr methodologies and then there's
high-resolution melting analysis which
is a method that we're going to talk
about more today when you consider the
challenges that are in front of you as
genotype errs really there's a number of
questions that I think everyone should I
be asking themselves beforehand and it's
really sort of agnostic of particular
accompanying solutions but really did
help you know guide you cannon recommend
you consider these questions first are
you trying to discover new mutations are
you looking for the unknown or trying to
test the very specific individual
mutation so if you're really sort of
discovery you may be looking at I want
to look at any mutations within the
entire genome the exome a particular
panel of genes even a particular gene or
even within a particular region of a
gene that's contrast very sharply by the
notion of testing which is I would like
to test for that at the presence of this
specific mutation an example would be
like a live mutation in fact you're 54
thrombophilia another consideration when
selecting a genotyping tulips how many
samples do you have do you have a
thousand samples are they all banked are
you having a rolling submission where
you get a dozen samples a day or is this
something more modest where you have a
very close
system maybe you only need to test a
dozen samples in total excuse me and
sample number and the way that you're
acquiring those samples can obviously
impact which technology you might want
to choose next a sample amount what type
of sample is it is it coming from a
fixed sample is it a fresh blood sample
is it isolated genomic DNA do you have
an excessive amount of the sample do you
have micrograms of DNA to play with
there is just a very few min even
nanograms of DNA that was isolated from
a fine needle biopsy something like this
and then the last question that we
recommend that you consider when
selecting genotyping technology or what
are the resources that you have
available to you and what I mean by that
is not only how many people do you have
available and what their workload is and
not only what sort of budget and cost
you're willing to put towards the
genotyping effort but even what is the
technical expertise of the people you
know that you have do you want them
spending their time on the genotyping
methodology that requires a robust level
of bioinformatic analysis or would you
rather you know those resources be
applied to other things and these are
complex considerations and by using the
intersection of these you can serve way
out which particular technology is the
best one for you at that given moment
and so focusing on that the difference
between that discovery and testing I
wanted to highlight when particular
focused studies might be required and
they really break down into three areas
there's pre-screening samples your
screen examples and then there's the
verification what I mean by
pre-screening is a prospective study
this is really I want to look at samples
before I take an unbiased approach so I
want to include or exclude them from my
further research study by doing that you
can then save costs and sort of limit
the amount of work that you might have
to do in a moment more laborious
discovery-based experiment screening
would be the opposite reg this would be
more of a retrospective study and a good
example of this in the basic research
laboratory is when you're doing
crisper clone generation so if you're
trying to edit the genome to introduce a
particular mutation in that particular
case you'll have a lot of clones that
won't have your targeted mutation and
you're trying to pick out the individual
ones that do and so you want to screen
through those very quickly and then the
last one is in verification and this
could be coming from you've done a sniff
microarray or an array CGH looking for
copy number and then you want to verify
the data that you got from those data
sets or you send a sample out for
sequencing so for instance you isolate
genomic DNA you send it out to a core
facility that's done the whole exome
sequencing sent you the data back and
you want to verify that the data that
you got back then indeed matches the
original sample that you collected and
so by using small numbers of snips you
can positively identify the data that
you received back matches indeed the
data for the sample that you sent out so
these are a couple of different examples
that I wanted to show you where you want
to maybe be taking a very targeted
approach and how you would use that
target approach to your benefit and to
do that one of the technologies that I
mentioned you could use is endpoint pcr
followed by high-resolution melting
analysis high-resolution melting
analysis is the classic technology it
leverages the biochemical aspects and
features of DNA so at low temperatures a
double DNA of course fuel forms the
double helix that's shown on the left
hand side of this screen if in that
solution there's a DNA intercalate and
die present and it'll bind to that
double-stranded DNA and give up for us
and signal and so maximum signal and
that all of the adult with dnase
double-stranded as you heat that sample
as shown on the x-axis the DNA will
unwind melt and fall apart informed just
have to single-stranded of forms that
single strand DNA I've been occurs at
high temperatures of DNA intercalating
guy comes off and the fluorescence
signal is lost
so the point in which half the
fluorescent signal is lost is that
temperature didn't refer to as the
melting temperature or key now excuse me
so there are two types of acids that can
be used to that can be designed in PCR
to use high-resolution melted I've shown
them here one is a small amplicon acid
that's shown on the left hand side so
this is where you just have two primers
creating the amplicon and on the right
hand side is an unlabeled probe at site
so the small amplicon assay simply
creates an amplicon and because of its
confusing because of the difference in
GC content of the amplicon the ears in
are going to melt at different
temperatures and you can see the
differences in the melting curves as
compared to the last slide shown here on
the left on the right hand side is the
unlabeled probe at say and this is where
maybe the short amplicons don't give you
enough resolution and shape and size to
be able to be easily distinguish so what
you do is you create a user forward and
reverse primer but generating an
amplicon and then an unlabeled probe is
added to the reaction and that unlabeled
probe binding so much smaller form
portion of the amplicon and you can see
that in a in this right hand side that's
or that middle graph and that kinda
creates this hetero species and that
then can be clearly distinguished when
you go under the melting conditions
shown in be so it makes much easier to
distinguish the melting profile so these
are classic ways to use HRM assets
they've been used in snips somatic
mutations insertions deletions
mitochondrial targets copy number
measurement as well as DNA methylation
so you can use a state solutions for
answering focus questions and what we
mean by that is there are two things one
there's the addressing of a difficult or
tough target and then there's two using
this technology to simplify your
workflow for the experimental process in
your laboratory I'm going to far the
first focus on tough targets on the left
hand side of the screen and I'm what I
mean by that is there's difficult
sequences to design assets or by other
pcr methodologies multi-target
discrimination so when snips are very
close to one another insertions and
deletions of all different sizes can
create the difficulty and analysis by
pcr mitochondrial targets and
heteroplasmy and finally copy number and
do the time restrictions i'm going to
focus on just a couple of those i'm
going to start with copy number or
excuse me i'm going to share with
insertions and deletions so this is data
that we're presenting at the upcoming
association of molecular pathology
meeting next week in charlotte north
carolina where the authors from our
group here at Canyon yo so scientists
can biomedical has designed assays using
HRM for detecting insertions and
deletions arranged from a single base
pair up all the way to several kilobases
and to focus on one of those there's
mutations in hex a gene that are
associated with ty Sachs disease this is
an inherited human developmental just
sort of that gradually destroys nerve
cells it's characterized by seizures
intellectual disability paralysis and
lots of your eyesight hearing and so
some of the documented genetic
variations that are involved in thai sex
disease and hex a include a very large
solution that measures seven in that all
a little over 17 half kilobases and the
authors of our publication clearly
identify an HR a massive it's capable of
distinguishing the presence of
distillation both in a heterozygous and
homozygous form so the HRM data that
I'll show throughout the presentation
you'll see the black curve represents
the wild-type samples the blue Sam
samples represented of the heterozygote
and a red sample represents the variant
homozygous and so you can see at
different melting temperatures the
different amplicons that are formed
using this assay this assay is
commercially available and I've noted
the catalog number here in the slides
for your reference later another
difficult target though of course is
mitochondrial target them this is data
that we shared at the American Society
of Human Genetics meeting the lead
author Ling Chow presented this and as
background knowledge over 14 different
diseases and disorders are now related
to mutations that not occur in a nuclear
genome but rather in the mitochondrial
genome the DNA that's inside DNA inside
the mitochondria and they're not
commercially available fast sensitive
and cost-effective assays for detecting
these mutations so in her presentation
she highlighted studies of focused on
these five mitochondrial DNA targets so
I've listed the jeans and those are
kinds of disorders there as well murph
me laughs and lhon the associated DB
smith buggies and then the annotation
there on the right hand side is whether
it's an unlabeled pro based assay of the
short amplicon type asset and so you can
see that we use a mix of these assays so
for one of them um highlighted here for
the mitochondrial myopathy and suckle op
electric acid acidosis and stroke-like
episode disease is a genetically
heterogeneous disorder has a variable
phenotype but the most common mutation
is this three to four three a2g
transition in the team and you can see
this is an unlabeled probe a sec so you
can see the very tall peak on the right
hand side of this graph there that
represents the full size amplicon but
then focusing in the next slide on just
the probe amplicon heteroduplex you can
clearly see that there's
the distinguishing between the wild-type
the heterozygote and the varied
homozygous for this particular mutation
and this a is also commercially
available well what's really interesting
about mitochondrial targets is that the
mutations that are in the mitochondrial
genome don't have to be in all of the
mitochondria so each mitochondria can
contain between 2 to 10 copies of the
mitochondrial genome their range but on
average there are several hundred copies
or several hundred mitochondria in each
cell and so you can imagine that only a
portion of all those mitochondrial
genomes will contain a mutation there's
a beautiful study that was done several
years ago that demonstrated that the
more copies of a mutation that are
present that there's a more severe
phenotype that that's presented so in
the case of this in the RR f there's a
differential phenotype of phenotype when
they first stratified the patient
population by age and then a safe or
presence of the mutation the more copies
of the mutation of a present the more
severe the phenotype is so Ling Shaw
presented at her poster at ahg in 2016
that by creating different add mixtures
that the sensitivity could be detected
down to thirteen percent of the
mitochondrial genome could then contain
the mutation to be detected by this
aspect the last example that I wanted to
share with you is another presentation
that was given by the R&D group it can
on copy number detection by using
high-resolution melting so this is
looking at smn1 copy number specifically
but to give you a sense of scale to be
an impact of copy number variation on
human disease there's over 500,000
variations that have been documented
they drive over ten percent of all the
gene expression changes that are no and
so they represent a really significant
driver in human biology diverse
and pathophysiology specifically smn1 it
accounts for about ninety five percent
of the spinal muscular atrophy cases
there's a deletion of the estimate one
gene that can even take it down to one
copy or two or zero copies very
difficult to design athletes for because
there's an estimate to gene the smn2
gene is virtually identical to the x-men
1 gene and what the authors here showed
using a cane clinical samples research
samples is that using an unlabeled probe
a fate excuse me using a duplex acid
that they were able to then distinguish
here between the black red and blue
curves of the two copies of the teen
prison one copy or zero copies be in
prison and they use the e curve that you
see here is an ultraconserved element in
the human genome that's used really as a
loading control on this essay is not
kerchak currently commercially available
to summarize the tough target portion of
the presentation what I've been able to
show you this data using HRM assays for
the detection of insertions and
deletions of varying lengths I've showed
you how you can use those assays to
detect Heather a plasma commute ations
in the mitochondrial genome and how
those that quantification of or
detection of different levels of
mutation then could have an impact on
phenotypic presentation and I've also
showed me how that you can use HRM now
to quantify copy number using
alternative approach in PCR and HRM
based assays make the difficult genetic
variations really accessible to the
individual laboratory so moving on into
simple genotyping there really a couple
of different ideas here one would be
that it's an easy protocol and i want to
show you that it can deal with sample
numbers and i'm going to talk a little
bit about data analysis so hopefully
most of you are familiar with
go for pcr but the HR alisis portion
really doesn't complicate the protocol
you have to take your sample your
research samples of interest you extract
the DNA we recommend it use the same
protocol or extraction method to isolate
your DNA then you create a reaction
mixture so you mix DNA together with
master mix that contains a polymerase
nucleotides etc as well as the assay and
some water together the master mix that
we recommend with the Nova little acid
is the Nobel genotyping master mix which
is designed for rapid pcr and
high-resolution melting finally when you
take those reaction mixtures you pipette
them into the appropriate reaction
chamber plates tubes and you put it into
your instrument that can perform PCR are
followed by high-resolution melting so
in general these are instruments that
have some sort of fluorescent detection
capability a lot of times it's a real
time PCR external and then finally from
the data analysis most instruments that
have high resolution melting also have
an included data analysis package so
what type of instruments am i referring
to I've just listed off some of the ones
that we've tested our own laboratories
that we know that are compatible with
high-resolution melting and
high-resolution melted analysis so a
couple from bio-rad the CFX 96 and 384
from roche there's the lightcycler 480
in the light cyclic to thermo fisher
life technologies ABI it's the quant
Studios certainly compatible from kaijin
the rotor gene q has an HR and module
and from bio fire there's a LS 32
instrument so from so that's really true
from how easy it is to use how easy
would be to using our laboratory
perspective and what I want to spend
most of the rest of the time is talking
really about how data analysis impacts
your experimental design and how you dey
analysis is
so I'm going to contrast for a second
and step back from high-resolution
melting and talk about the current
methodologies that are used by pcr and
those require fluorescent probes in this
particular case which you can see this
is example data using a hydrolysis probe
attack man probe there's two colors one
for signal on the x-axis and one a lot
of the fam and hex fluorescence and what
you can see is that the experiment is in
terms of balances the samples out where
the genotype that's homozygous for one
allele is in red the others blue and
then the heterozygous cases in black and
you can see that all of the signal would
be in one color for a homicide it and
then when the signal is kind of mixed
and that's what really creates the
heterozygote the data analysis
methodologies that draw to this really
didn't require clustering so it's when
the signals are located together that
you can then say okay the red cluster
all goes together the blue cluster goes
together the black cluster all goes
together now when you run experiments in
on different days or even more in the
afternoon you're going to get data sets
and what you can see here is in the and
the top two figures are ones that were
run same instrument but these are on
different days here's the sample the
data that was collected so you can see
wow you think the red go together you
take the black go together and we would
go together but the challenge is that
then when you can actually combine these
data sets into a larger analysis you
really don't get the same three clusters
and what you really get our six clusters
and that makes the day mouse that's very
very difficult to then combine into
larger data sets well why is this a
challenge and the challenge really stems
from the idea that then you need to
enough samples to then create these
different genotypes clusters this is in
contrast to high-resolution melting
analysis where you really don't have to
you know have maybe a control sample for
instance the wild-type and then your
experimental simple and you could
clearly then differentiate by just
shape and location of the peaks and
individual genotype so you don't really
require clustering it can be done on an
individual sample basis so you can
sample literally one sample at the
genotype 1 sample at a time this
clustering also then you know impacts
your algorithm and so the challenge here
is if you don't have enough samples you
don't necessarily create all of these
different clusters and so I want to show
you some data this is a data set that
was created using genotyping just six
samples you see the notes how to play
control in the lower left hand corner
and the gray you see a black triangle
and then the the five blue dots and if
you were to analyze to say you'd say
well the blue dots look like you know
how much i get for one allele the black
triangle probably represents the Hat
enters i go sample well if you look now
at an expanded set of data where more
samples were included now what we see is
okay we still see our gray dots but no
template control in the lower left-hand
corner lower right hand corner we have
the blue and then in the center we have
the black dots but notice our black
triangle from the previous data set has
now moved down into the blue cluster and
now is blue so you've changed the
genotyping call for that sample from a
head to a home the reason that this has
happened has been highlighted by the red
arrows the analysis software that's out
there for clustering for fluorescent
probe based pcr auto scales to data and
so if you don't have enough raw data to
create the different clusters the
software won't auto scale the axes and
you will actually unfortunately
misinterpret the data potentially make
an errant call so because of the
limitations of the algorithm it really
that does dictate how you design your
experiments so as a summary for the
simple genotyping portion of my talk as
you can see it's a very simple protocol
it's running just a standard pcr your
isolate DNA create a reaction mixture
put into your pc our air instrument it's
already available in your laboratory
that performs high-resolution melting
and then you can
data for as little as a single sample so
you don't have to batch data up till the
end of the week you don't have to worry
about trying to combine data sets and
clustering algorithms are not going to
fool your data interpretation so this
again allow you know yields HRM based
assays is how to make difficult
experiments accessible to you in a
laboratory and so what I'm really trying
to pain for you as a picture is that HRM
based assays allow you to address
difficult target things that have
difficult sequence large deletions
heteroplasmy mitochondrial DNA targets
copy number measurements and all of this
can be done in your own laboratories
using a very simple protocol very easy
to do data analysis and you can do it in
as few as as many samples as you would
like Canon biomedical is commercialized
our expertise in HRM at they design into
some products that are shown here the
novo genotyping assays that are
available for other sniffs or insertions
and deletions you then can we recommend
using the associate no loyalty no typing
master mix which is a we're at the
chemistry generally the protocol takes
less than an hour for the run these are
shipped to you under environmental
conditions so it saves some money on
shipping and then you just store them in
the refrigerator so that you can really
set up your reactions assuming as
quickly as you'd like if you already
have designed to HRM and would like to
use our rapid chemistry then you can
essentially just convert your essay over
to our chemistry using the 2x all of
them not all of the elution buffer so
with this you know I've talked a lot
about different biological conditions
and I've talked about the mechanics and
technical information behind high
resolution melting there are different
ways to find our assays on our website
I've shown you to hear one on the left
hand side of super interest in
particular area of biology can browse
through cancer or cardiovascular immune
disease neuroscience pharmacogenetics
for listings of assays or you can use
our search interface and
through the magic of the lab roots
virtual webinar virtual presentation
we're now going to push you a link
that's going to open up in your browser
a new window or a new tab and that's
going to now open up the link for how to
go ahead and go ahead and search our
website for your own target of interest
so you can choose those application
areas if you want to if you're
interested in pharmacogenetics look at
that drop-down menu for drug you can
actually look for the variations that
are associated with individual drugs we
have over a hundred and sixty different
drugs listed but you can look at the
association of variants and that's all
driven by the farm gkb database so we're
going to push that link to you now that
it opens up in your web browser so that
you can play with that with that I'm
going to go ahead and wrap up here
through my history presentation at the
beginning of today's talk i was able to
talk about how can a biomedical is your
new partner environmental research we
actively do look for collaborations with
other companies as evidenced by our work
with t2 Biosystems and spark Biosciences
we're working with universities develop
interesting genotyping targets and we've
now launched that commercially to you as
the research community in the form of
the noble assays and chemistry that are
designed for rapid pcr followed by HRM
we have a lot more products that are
going to be coming out in the very very
near term so i hope do hope you stay
tuned for that so with that I'm going to
say thank you very much I certainly
appreciate you guys hanging on there
with me through my getting over my cold
so thank you very much for that we're
going to go ahead and start taking
questions and then I'm going to go ahead
and also ask my last poll question for
today is we're going to push out is if
you would like we can go ahead and
actively follow up with you about our
solutions or provide additional
information so if you go ahead now and
just go ahead and answer the poll that's
coming up if you'd like a can of our
medical representative to follow up with
you to talk about your tough genotyping
challenges and maybe how we could
simplify it for you please go ahead and
say yes we'd be happy to contact you and
see if we could support you more
directly
and with that I also encourage you to
open up the question answer tab and go
ahead and fill out whatever questions
that you might have for me to go ahead
and answer with that I'd like to say
thanks well here it's been a quote
pressure just excellent presentation dr.
McNally thanks for bringing that
information to all of us and as you
already touched on before we get started
with all your questions here's a quick
reminder about how to reach us today
questions can be sent and see the green
Q&A button at the lower left of the
presentation window we'll get to as many
of them as we can and let's see we
already have a few questions queued up
for you the first one is may I send
samples to Canon for genotyping okay you
know that's a great question we get this
a lot kata biomedical really right now
is focused on providing solutions that
are simply using more laboratory canon
biomedical does not accept samples where
we do it as a service if you typically
send your samples out to a core
laboratory for genotyping certainly you
can encourage them to contact us and
we'd be happy to work with those core
laboratories to provide that service the
Canon biomedical does not offer
genotyping as a service today okay that
is good to know okay the next question
here is kind of a compound question and
it asks what is the best sensitivity of
HRM somatic mutation detection it can if
you reached in other words i mean what
percent mutated DNA against WT
background yeah great question so there
are published examples going below what
we have published but if you look at the
heteroplasmy example for mitochondrial
that's really sort of a very similar
experiment where we created add mixtures
diluting out a particular mutation in
that particular case the percent
mutation that was detected was 13 but
that
thirteen percent now that's really i
would consider an over estimate though
if you focus on some annotations you can
drive that percentage using HRM to
something that's far lower probably by
about a factor of five to ten in the
published reports that i've read so i
hope that helped that's great
information and there is actually
another follow up here it says what kind
of be in a control should we use for h
RM amplicons or plasmas or human DNA
human DNA sample yeah I mean I think
most you know most of the reviewers that
are out there would certainly encourage
you to use authentic human samples
however from the perspective of the
analysis amplicons and Pleasance
amplicons are a little bit better to
work with if you were going to do
plasmids out say you want to linearize
it and then the only thing that i would
encourage you to remember is that excuse
me the DNA that you want to put into the
reaction should be in an equivalent
buffer so you don't want to you know
prep for instance DNA samples using
different DNA isolation kits so we just
recommend that they are an equivalent
buffers when you put it into the
reaction so first choice would be human
DNA example second choice would be
amplicons excellent excellent okay our
next question with copies of
mitochondrial genes also being present
in the nuclear genome how do you know
that the various you are detecting are
not coming from the nuclear genome it's
a great question there are examples of
the mitochondrial genes my country of
genome having insertions in the gym
genome the signal that we would that
we're detecting would be clearly above
that detection limits so as an example
as I
try to point out during the course of
the talk there are anywhere between two
and ten copies of the mitochondrial
genome in a Cell in a mitochondria and
then there's hundreds of copies of
mitochondria in a cell and that would
easily sort of out number the one or two
copies of mitochondrial gene in the
human genome that in combination with a
robust bioinformatic base design for the
Alice's that would control for any sort
of pseudo genes or specific our non
specific targets are also being
addressed so that's why we're confident
that the variance as I showed you in the
publication are not resulting from a
copy of a nuclear genome all right thank
you for that and let's see dr. McNally
looks like we have one final question so
if you'd like to answer this and enclose
that with any final comments please do
so the last question here asks how
should I analyze HRM data that's a good
question so we've indicated that the HRM
is really something that most
fluorescent basement thermal cyclers are
compatible with and in a lot of those
instances the interns themselves come
with an h RM analysis module so we would
encourage you to begin with your
analysis using the included software
that you essentially already purchased
on your instrument so you don't really
have to go out and purchase additional
software options wonderful wonderful and
with that any closing comments or okay
looks like we are digging in Jordan my
side yeah yes you have anything else
okay well let's see well thank you so
much once again dr. McNally I'd like to
thank our speaker dr. Brian McNally as
as well as our sponsor Canon biomedical
for making it possible to bring this
presentation to you today's webcast will
be available for on-demand viewing
through februari 2017 you will receive
an email from us lab roots alerting you
when it is available for on-demand and
it will also be posted on labrys com you
are welcome to afford this announcement
to any of your colleagues who weren't
able to join join us today thanks for
logging on and participating in today's
broadcast we'll see you next time here
at lab ribs